Today we'd like to
explore the idea
of the center of mass,
or the center of gravity,
of a rigid object.
For instance, take this rod.
And if I try to
balance it on my finger
at a certain point
in that rod, I'm
balancing it via the
gravitational force.
And this point is often
referred to as the center
of gravity of the rod.
Now, if we were in empty space
with no gravitational field,
then center of gravity
doesn't make any sense.
But this point still
coincides with what
we call the center of
mass of the object.
And now I'd like to
define center of mass.
So let's consider
our rigid body.
And we'll just describe
it as some object--
we'll make it idealized--
and that there's
going to be trying to find
some point in this object.
And we'll identify that
point as the center of mass.
Now, let's imagine that
this rigid body is made up
of a bunch of little pieces.
So we have m, j.
And this j piece is
located from the center
of mass, a vector rcm.
Now how we want to define
this particular point
is that when we
make the sum from j
equals 1 to n over every
single point in this body,
then that will be 0.
And this will be the definition
of the center of mass,
that when you add up the
position vector with respect
to this point
weighted by the mass,
and you add up all of those
vectors, you'll get 0.
Now, if you don't know where
the center of mass is then
this is difficult to calculate.
So let's find a way where you
choose an arbitrary point,
and that's write that arbitrary
point, say, over here.
We'll write it like this-- s.
And we'll treat
that as our origin.
And I'll draw a vector, rsj.
And here, I'll draw
the vector Rcm.
And now what we have from
our vector relationship
is that the vector rsj
equals the vector Rcm--
and that's what I want to
find-- plus the vector rcmj.
And now let's add up-- multiply
each of these by the mass
and make a sum.
So we have mj rsj
equals the sum of mj.
Now, the vector
Rcm, this vector,
no matter where we picked
a point in this object,
the vector's always the same.
And that's why I pulled
it out of the sum.
And over here, I
have the sum from j
goes from 1 to n, j
1 to n, of mj rcmj.
Now, recall, this
is precisely how
we define the center of
mass point, that this is 0.
And so we can now conclude
that the center of mass--
so you pick an arbitrary
point, and if you want
to find that vector to the
center of mass, what you do
is you make the sum from j
goes from 1 to n of mj rsj,
and you divide that by
j goes from 1 to n, mj.
And this is what we
call the center of mass.
So conceptually,
the center of mass
is the point in
the object where,
if you take a vector to any
of the little mass elements,
and you weight it by the mass
element, and you add them up,
you get 0.
If you wanted to calculate the
center of mass about any point,
you choose a point, s,
you draw the vector from s
to the object.
You sum up those vectors.
We see by our
vector triangle rule
that we can now calculate
that center of mass vector
by this equation.
And now let's just rewrite this
because this is the total mass.
And what we see is that the
Rcm equals j goes from 1 to n,
mj rsj divided by
the total mass.